From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. OK, so maybe you saw in the news that Defense Secretary Pete Hegseth has ordered everybody in the Armed Services over 30 years old to have their testosterone levels tested. That's men and women, both. And then anybody who wants to get special shots to get testosterone boost, they can get them.
来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。好吧，也许你在新闻里看到了，国防部长皮特·赫格塞斯下令要求武装部队中所有30岁以上的人员进行睾酮水平检测。无论男女，一律如此。而且，任何想要获得睾酮补充特别注射的人，都可以去接种。
The goal here-- Hegseth's social media post about this was titled The High T-- High Testosterone-- Department of War. And maybe you saw. People who had all kinds of reactions to this, including lots of people joking about how Hegseth was suddenly embracing gender-affirming care.
其目标是——赫格塞斯在社交媒体上发布的内容标题为《高T——高睾酮——战争部》。也许你看到了。人们对此有各种各样的反应，包括许多人开玩笑说赫格塞斯突然开始拥护所谓的“性别肯定护理”了。
I personally had a strong reaction to the idea of testing everybody's testosterone levels in a workplace, which was, I've lived through that here at my job at This American Life. We did that back in 2002. We did a show where we talked about testosterone and the personality traits that supposedly go along with higher testosterone levels.
我个人对在一个工作场所测试所有人的睾酮水平这一想法有着强烈的反应，因为我在《美国生活》的工作中经历过类似的事。我们曾在2002年做过那次实验。我们做了一期节目，讨论了睾酮以及据称与高睾酮水平相关的人格特质。
And as part of that show, all of us on staff got our testosterone levels tested to see who had the highest. And then before the results came back, we all sat down and discussed who we thought might have the highest. And then we revealed the results.
作为那期节目的一部分，我们全体员工都接受了睾酮水平测试，看看谁的水平最高。在结果出来之前，我们坐在一起讨论了谁可能是最高的那个人。然后，我们揭晓了结果。
Anyway, today, as a cautionary tale to the men and women of the Armed Services about what it's like for an entire workplace to test their testosterone, we are rerunning that old show. Our staff experiment, you'll hear, comes up a little ways into the show. It's Act Two. But the original episode started with one of our producers at the time, Alex Blumberg, joining me in the studio to explain why we took up the subject in the first place back in 2002.
总之，今天，作为一个给武装部队男女官兵的警示故事，告诉他们整个工作场所都进行睾酮测试是什么样的体验，我们将重播那期旧节目。你会听到，我们的员工实验在节目进行了一小部分之后出现，那是在第二幕。但最初的那集节目是以当时的一位制片人亚历克斯·布隆伯格在演播室和我一起解释我们为何在2002年最初选择这个主题作为开头的。
Hello, Ira.
你好，艾拉。
Alex.
亚历克斯。
Yes?
怎么了？
What's the reason for this week's show?
本周节目的主题是什么原因？
Well, I've been thinking about that. And for me, the reason for today's program goes back to a book I read when I was 15 called The Women's Room. Maybe people listening will remember The Women's Room. It was sort of a seminal feminist novel from the '70s.
嗯，我一直在思考这个问题。对我来说，今天节目的起因要追溯到我15岁时读的一本书，叫《女性房间》。也许听众会记得《女性房间》。那算是70年代一本具有开创意义的女权主义小说。
And I first came across The Women's Room when I was digging through my parents' bookshelves looking for porn, books with naughty parts in them, like Fear of Flying. And so I picked it up, and I read it.
我第一次接触到《女性房间》是在我翻阅父母书架寻找色情内容时，也就是那些有“露骨”情节的书，比如《飞向恐惧》。所以我拿起来读了。
Because the word "women" was in the title.
就因为标题里有“女性”这个词。
In lipstick, probably-- or maybe not.
大概是用唇膏写的吧——或者也许不是。
Yes.
是的。
It's incredibly polemical. It describes basically a group of women going from the '50s through the '60s. And they all suffer at the hands of the various men in their lives. And women are slowly being driven crazy by their husband's incessant criticism, or they're being called ugly after they get mastectomies, or they're being stifled by their husband's emotional shallowness.
它极具论战性。它描述了一群女性从50年代到60年代的生活。她们都受苦于生命中各种男人的折磨。她们被丈夫不断的批评逼疯，或者在切除乳房后被称作丑陋，又或者被丈夫情感上的浅薄所窒息。
And I noticed you happen to have brought into the studio with you today a copy of The Women's Room.
我注意到你今天正好带了一本《女性房间》到演播室。
Yeah, well, I recently reread it just to see. For example, I bookmarked a couple of these things. On page 198, the narrator comes in. And she says, "You think I hate men. I guess I do."
是啊，我最近重读了一遍，就是想看看。比如，我给其中几处做了书签。在第198页，叙述者登场了。她说：“你以为我恨男人。我想我确实恨。”
And then a little bit further down, she says, "My feelings about men are the result of my experience. I have little sympathy for them. Like a Jew just released from Dachau, I watched the handsome young Nazi soldier fall writhing to the ground with a bullet in his stomach. And I look briefly and walk on. I don't even need to shrug. I simply don't care."
然后往下一点，她说：“我对男人的感觉是我经验的结果。我几乎对他们没有任何同情。就像一个刚从达豪集中营释放出来的犹太人，我看着那个英俊的年轻纳粹士兵腹部中弹，在地上痛苦挣扎。我只是匆匆看了一眼就走开了。我甚至不需要耸耸肩。我只是完全不在乎。”
And then a little bit later, "My hatred is learned from experience. That is not prejudice. I wish it were prejudice. Then, perhaps, I could unlearn it."
接着过了一会儿又写道：“我的恨意源于经验。那不是偏见。我希望那是偏见。那样的话，也许我还能消除它。”
There's not very much pornographic about that.
那里面可没什么色情成分。
It's an incredibly strange thing to read this book at that age. Because at that age, I felt like there's one other woman who comes into play at this point. And I probably shouldn't say her name. Let's just call her Kelly.
在那个年纪读这本书是一件极其奇怪的事情。因为在那个年纪，我觉得那时还有另一个女人出现在我的生活中。我可能不该说出她的名字。我们暂且叫她凯利吧。
And she was in eighth grade with me. And she sat two rows away from me. And I remember, one time, sitting in homeroom with her and seeing her button-down shirt was open a little bit. And I could catch the bare sliver of her little training bra.
她和我同在八年级。她坐在离我两排远的地方。我记得有一次在班主任课上，看到她的扣子衬衫稍微敞开了一点。我能瞥见她那小小的训练文胸的一角。
And it was perhaps the most desire I've ever felt in my life, maybe. It was, like, all consuming. And I couldn't concentrate for the rest of the day. I remember it to this day.
那可能是我一生中感受到的最强烈的渴望，也许吧。那简直是吞噬一切的感受。我那一整天都没法集中精力。直到今天我还记得那件事。
And so, at the time I was reading this book, I felt like, oh, my God. I could see myself becoming the people that she was describing, the men she was describing. And it was really terrifying.
所以，当时读那本书时，我感觉到，天哪，我能看到自己正变成书中描述的那些人，那些男人。这真的很可怕。
My testosterone and how it affects me and how I react to it, I think about on a daily basis, all the time. It often feels like there's something in my body giving me instructions that I probably shouldn't follow.
我的睾酮，它如何影响我，我如何对它产生反应，这些我每天都在想，一直在想。它常让我觉得身体里有什么东西在给我下达我可能不该遵循的指令。
OK, which brings us to today's program. A while back, Alex tried to convince all of us who work on the radio show that we should do an entire program about testosterone. And I have to say, none of us were really buying it, especially the women, who found the subject dull, even though, as Alex tried to point out to them, women have testosterone, and it affects them pretty much exactly the same way that it affects men.
好的，这引出了今天的节目。不久前，亚历克斯试图说服我们所有为电台节目工作的人，我们要围绕睾酮做一整期节目。不得不说，我们没人买账，尤其是女性，她们觉得这个话题很乏味，尽管正如亚历克斯试图向她们指出的那样，女性体内也有睾酮，而且它对她们产生的影响和对男性几乎是一样的。
I think all of us were fearing a kind of "men are from Mars, women are from Venus" sort of thing, how hormones make men be all aggressive and women all nonaggressive in very stereotyped ways, which all seem kind of reductionistic and dumb headed. And then Alex started reading and calling people. And one of the people that he called was this guy who wrote an article for GQ Magazine about what happened to him when, because of medical reasons, he stopped producing testosterone. And for four months, he lived without testosterone before they caught the problem. And the way he described living without testosterone was really incredible.
我想我们都在担心会变成那种“男人来自火星，女人来自金星”式的论调，比如荷尔蒙如何让男人变得咄咄逼人，让女人变得温和，表现出极端的刻板印象，这看起来既简化又愚蠢。然后亚历克斯开始阅读并联系相关人员。他联系的一个人是一位给《GQ》杂志写过文章的男士，讲述了他因医疗原因停止产生睾酮后发生的事情。他在四个月的时间里在没有睾酮的情况下生活，直到他们查出了问题。他描述那种没有睾酮的生活方式真是令人难以置信。
Everything that I identify as being me-- my ambition, my interest in things, my sense of humor, the inflection in my voice-- the quality of my speech even changed in the time that I was without a lot of the hormone. So yes, the introduction of testosterone returned everything. There were things that I find offensive about my own personality that were disconnected then. And it was nice to be without them.
所有我认定的那个“我”——我的抱负、我对事物的兴趣、我的幽默感、我说话的语调——甚至我在缺乏大量该荷尔蒙期间说话的质感都变了。所以，是的，补充睾酮后一切都恢复了。我曾发现自己人格中一些令人反感的部分，在那段时间里消失了。那种感觉很棒。
Envy, the desire to judge itself-- I approached people with a humility that I had never displayed before. I grew up in a culture, like all of us, that divides the soul from the body, and that that is your singleness. That is your uniqueness.
嫉妒，那种去评判他人的欲望——我以一种我从未表现过的谦卑态度对待他人。我和我们所有人一样，在一种将灵魂与肉体分离的文化中长大，认为那才是你的唯一性。那才是你的独特性。
And then I go through this experience where I have small amounts of a bodily chemical removed and then reintroduced. And it changes everything I know as my self. And it violates the sanctity of that understanding. And that's humbling. And it's terrifying.
然后我经历了这种体验，身体里少了少量的化学物质，又被重新补充进去。它改变了我所知的一切自我。它侵犯了那种理解的神圣性。这让人感到卑微。而且很可怕。
I think, when it comes to this stuff, most of us do not know what to believe. We're caught between thinking that our hormones and body chemistry can determine so much about our personalities and wanting to believe that they don't. And so today on our program, we bring you four stories exploring that question.
我想，涉及到这些东西时，我们大多数人不知道该相信什么。我们在认为荷尔蒙和身体化学物质能决定我们性格的很大一部分，与想要相信它们并不能决定之间摇摆。所以今天在我们的节目中，我们带给你四个探索这个问题的故事。
How much does testosterone determine? Act One of our show, Infinite Gent-- someone gets pumped up with several times the amount of testosterone that most men have and describe some surprising changes. Act Two, Contest-osterone. In that act, at Alex's suggestion, all of us on the staff of this radio program decide to find out who has the most and who has the least testosterone, with lab tests, to see how the levels match with our personality traits-- an exercise, I have to say, most of us at this point would not recommend that you try at your workplace or with your friends.
睾酮到底决定了多少？节目的第一幕，“无限绅士”——有人被注入了比大多数男性体内多几倍的睾酮，并描述了一些令人惊讶的变化。第二幕，“比赛睾酮”。在那一幕中，在亚历克斯的建议下，我们节目的全体员工决定通过实验室测试来找出谁的睾酮最多、谁的最少，看看这些水平与我们的人格特质是否匹配——不得不说，这是一个我们目前绝不建议你在工作场所或与朋友一起尝试的练习。
Act Three, Life at Zero, in which we hear about what it means to lose all your testosterone. Act Four, Learning to Shut Up-- in that act, a mother asks her teenage son all her questions about what it means to be a boy, which is, of course, exactly of thing you do not want your mother asking you on tape at 15. Stay with us.
第三幕，“零度生活”，我们会听到失去所有睾酮意味着什么。第四幕，“学会闭嘴”——在那一幕中，一位母亲问她十几岁的儿子所有关于作为男孩意味着什么的问题，这当然正是你15岁时最不想让你母亲在录音时问你的事情。请继续收听。
It's This American Life, act one, Infinite Gent. So what exactly does an injection of testosterone do to you? What kind of changes do you feel? Back in 2002, when we first broadcast today's show, our producer, Alex Blumberg, talked with Griffin Hansbury about that experience. Griffin got massive testosterone shots as part of transitioning from female to male, which Griffin did after he got out of college.
这是《美国生活》，第一幕，无限绅士。那么，一针睾酮到底会对你做什么？你会感受到什么样的变化？回到2002年，当我们首次播出今天的节目时，我们的制片人亚历克斯·布隆伯格与格里芬·汉斯伯里谈论了那种体验。格里芬在大学毕业后进行了从女性到男性的转变，作为过程的一部分，他接受了大量的睾酮注射。
I should tell you that, because it's been over 20 years since this interview happened, you might notice some ideas about gender and some language that are of its time. Also, a quick heads-up to listeners that the interview acknowledges the existence of sex and sexual desire.
我应该告诉你们，因为这个采访已经过去了20多年，你可能会注意到一些关于性别和语言的观念带有那个时代的特点。另外，给听众提个醒，这次采访涉及到了性及性欲的存在。
I went to Bryn Mawr College, which is a women's college, and chose a women's college because I strongly identified as a woman at the time, as a feminist, and as a dyke. I had my leather biker jacket and my big leather belt and my black T-shirts and my Doc Marten boots, my combat boots. And that felt pretty comfortable for a while.
我上了布林茅尔学院，那是一所女子学院。我选择女子学院是因为当时我强烈地认同自己是女性，是一名女权主义者，也是一个女同性恋。我穿着皮质机车夹克，戴着宽大的皮带，穿着黑色T恤和马汀靴，那种战斗靴。那一阵子我觉得挺自在的。
And then, my sophomore year in college, I was lying in bed with my girlfriend. I don't know if we were talking or what it was. And it just sort of hit me like a bolt of lightning, as they say. And I just knew that I had to change my body.
然后，在我大学二年级时，我和女朋友躺在床上。我不记得我们在谈话还是在做什么。那感觉就像闪电击中了我，正如人们常说的那样。我知道我必须改变我的身体。
And so I started doing the research on it. And the only way to do that was to take testosterone. My first injection was a pretty large one of 2 cc's of 200 milligram strength depo testosterone, which is a fairly high amount. Just to give you a sense of how much that is, the average amount of testosterone in an average male body is between 300 and 1,000 nanograms per deciliter of blood.
所以我开始做研究。唯一的方法就是服用睾酮。我的第一次注射量相当大，是2毫升200毫克强度的庚酸睾酮，这是一个相当高的剂量。为了让你了解这是多少，一个普通男性体内平均的睾酮水平在每分升血液300到1000纳克之间。
After that shot, and after an average shot, my testosterone levels go up to over 2,000 nanograms per deciliter so that I have the testosterone of two high-testosterone men in my body at once.
注射之后，平均水平下，我的睾酮水平会上升到每分升超过2000纳克，所以我体内同时拥有两个高睾酮男性的水平。
You have the testosterone of two linebackers.
你拥有两个线卫的睾酮。
Exactly.
没错。
Yeah.
是啊。
Exactly. That's a lot. It's a lot of T. And what's amazing about it is how instantaneous it is, that it happens within a few days, really. The world just changes.
没错。那很多。那是大量的T。令人惊奇的是它是多么即时，真的在几天内就发生了。世界完全变了。
What were some of the changes that you didn't expect?
你没预料到的一些变化是什么？
The most overwhelming feeling is the incredible increase in libido and change in the way that I perceived women and the way I thought about sex. Before testosterone, I would be riding the subway, which is the traditional hotbed of lust in the city. And I would see a woman on the subway. And I would think, she's attractive. I'd like to meet her. What's that book she's reading? If I could talk to her, this is what I would say. There would be a narrative. There would be this stream of language. It would be very verbal.
最压倒性的感觉是性欲的难以置信的增加，以及我感知女性和思考性方式的变化。在睾酮之前，我会乘坐地铁，那是城市中传统的欲望温床。我会看到地铁上的一个女人。我会想，她很有吸引力。我想认识她。她读的那本书是什么？如果我能和她谈谈，我会这么说。会有一个叙事。会有这种语言流。会非常口头化。
After testosterone, there was no narrative. There was no language whatsoever. It was just I would see a woman who was attractive or not attractive. She might have an attractive quality, nice ankles or something. And the rest of her would be fairly unappealing to me. But that was enough to basically just flood my mind with aggressive pornographic images, just one after another. It was like being in a pornographic movie house in my mind.
在睾酮之后，没有任何叙事。完全没有语言。我只是看到一个有吸引力或者没有吸引力的女人。她可能有一个迷人的特质，比如漂亮的脚踝之类的。而她身体的其他部分对我来说就没什么吸引力了。但这足以让我的脑海中涌入攻击性的色情画面，一个接一个。这就像是在脑子里置身于一家色情电影院一样。
And I couldn't turn it off. I could not turn it off. Everything I looked at, everything I touched, turned to sex. I was an editorial assistant. And I would be standing at the Xerox machine. And this big, shuddering, warm, inanimate object would just drive me crazy. It was very, very erotic to me.
而且我关不掉它。我没法关掉它。我看着的一切，触碰的一切，都变成了性。我曾经是编辑助理。我会站在复印机旁。这个巨大的、颤抖的、温暖的、无生命的物体就会让我疯狂。它对我来说非常、非常色情。
(LAUGHING) The Xerox machine.
（大笑）复印机。
The Xerox machine or a car. I would see-- I remember walking up 5th Avenue one day. And this red convertible went by. It was a Mustang. And I remember just getting this jolt in my pants, this very physical, visceral, sexual reaction to seeing a red convertible.
复印机或者一辆车。我看到——我记得有一天走在第五大道上。一辆红色敞篷车开过去。是野马。我记得当时裤裆里有一种冲击感，一种看到红色敞篷车时非常物理的、本能的性反应。
What did you do with that? What did you think?
你对此做了什么？你怎么想的？
[SCOFFS] Well, I felt like a monster a lot of the time. And it made me understand men. It made me understand adolescent boys a lot. Suddenly, hair is sprouting, and I'm turning into this beast. And I would really berate myself for it.
（冷笑）嗯，我大部分时间觉得自己是个怪物。这让我理解了男人。这让我非常理解青少年男孩。突然，毛发萌生，我变成了一头野兽。我真的会为此责备自己。
I remember walking up 5th Avenue. There was a woman walking in front of me. And she was wearing this little skirt and this little top. And I was looking at her ass. And I kept saying to myself, don't look at it. Don't look at it. And I kept looking at it. And I walked past her. And this voice in my head kept saying, turn around to look at her breasts. Turn around. Turn around. Turn around.
我记得走在第五大道上。一个女人走在我前面。她穿着短裙和短上衣。我在盯着她的屁股看。我一直对自己说，别看。别看。但我一直在看。我走过了她。脑子里的这个声音一直在说，回头看她的胸部。回头。回头。回头。
And my feminist, female background kept saying, don't you dare, you pig. Don't turn around. And I fought myself for a whole block. And then I turned around and checked her out. And before, it was cool. When I would do a poetry reading, I would get up, and I would read these poems about women on the street. And I was a butch dyke. And that was very, very cutting edge. And that was very sexy and raw. And now I'm just a jerk.
我那个女权主义、女性背景一直在说，你敢，你这头猪。别回头。我挣扎了整整一个街区。然后我回头看了她一眼。在那之前，这种行为很酷。当我做诗歌朗诵时，我会站起来，朗读关于街上女人的诗。我曾是一个硬朗的女同志。那是非常前卫的。那是非常性感和生动的。而现在，我只是个混蛋。
[LAUGHTER]
（大笑）
So I do feel like I've lost this edge, this nice, sort of avant garde kind of-- and I've gotten into a lot of arguments with women friends, co-workers who did not know about my past as a female. I call myself a post-feminist. And I had a woman say, you're not a post-feminist. You're a misogynist.
所以我确实觉得我失去了一些锋芒，那种漂亮的、某种先锋派的——而且我和那些不知道我过去是女性的朋友、同事吵过很多架。我称自己为后女权主义者。有个女人说，你不是后女权主义者。你是厌女症患者。
And I said, that's impossible. I can't be a misogynist. And I couldn't explain to her how I had come to this point in my life. And to her, I was just a misogynist. And that's unfortunate because it's a lot more complicated than that.
我说，那不可能。我怎么可能是厌女症患者。我无法向她解释我是如何走到今天这一步的。对她来说，我只是个厌女症患者。那很不幸，因为情况要复杂得多。
[LAUGHS] I'll say. Wow. Testosterone didn't just turn you into a man. It turned you into Rush Limbaugh.
（大笑）我敢说。哇。睾酮不只是把你变成了男人。它把你变成了拉什·林博。
I know. That, I was not expecting. That, I was not expecting. So I had to relearn how to talk to women. And I had to learn how to rephrase things, how to hold my tongue on certain things. And I'm not very good at it, so I get in trouble.
我知道。那是我没预料到的。那是我没预料到的。所以我必须重新学习如何与女性交谈。我必须学习如何重新表述事情，如何对某些事情保持沉默。我做得不太好，所以我总是惹麻烦。
That is so fascinating. Because as a man, I think, from the time I went through puberty, I feel like that's something that I've been learning to do in a certain way-- is just figure out how to say things without getting myself in trouble.
那太令人着迷了。因为作为一个男人，我想，从我经历青春期开始，我觉得那就是我一直在某种程度上学习做的事情——就是弄清楚如何在不给自己惹麻烦的情况下说出事情。
[LAUGHTER]
（大笑）
Right. Yeah. Yeah.
没错。是啊。是啊。
I would not have thought that you would have had that problem.
我没想过你会遇到那个问题。
Right. Because I should know better or something.
没错。因为我应该更懂事之类的。
Or something. Other than the visual and other than the libidinal, are there other ways that you feel like testosterone has altered the way you feel or perceive?
或者其他。除了视觉和性欲，你觉得睾酮还在其他方面改变了你的感受或感知吗？
Something that happened after I started taking testosterone-- I became interested in science. I was never interested in science before.
我在开始服用睾酮后发生的一件事——我对科学产生了兴趣。我以前对科学从不感兴趣。
No way. Come on. Are you serious?
不可能。算了吧。你是认真的吗？
[LAUGHTER]
（大笑）
I'm serious. I'm serious.
我是认真的。我是认真的。
You're just setting us back a hundred years, sir.
先生，你这简直是在让我们倒退一百年。
I know I am I know.
我知道，我知道。
[LAUGHTER]
（大笑）
Again, I have to have this caveat in here. I cannot say it was the testosterone. All I can say is that this interest happened after T. There's BT and AT. And this was definitely After T. And I became interested in science. I found myself understanding physics in a way I never had before.
再次重申，我得在这里加个免责声明。我不能说是睾酮带来的。我只能说这种兴趣发生在T之后。有T前和T后。这绝对是T后。我开始对科学感兴趣。我发现自己能以一种从未有过的方式理解物理学。
[LAUGHTER]
（大笑）
It's true. It's true.
这是真的。这是真的。
Wow.
哇。
I did.
我确实理解了。
How about in the way you feel things and in the way you perceive of your feelings? Is there any change there?
那你对感受事物的过程和你对自己感受的感知方式有什么改变吗？
[SIGHS] I have a hard time crying. It's very difficult for me to cry. And before testosterone, it was great to, if I was frustrated or angry or sad, have a good cry. You'd feel better afterwards. And I do wonder if there isn't a chemical component behind it. Because I now have a hard time doing it. And it's very frustrating.
（叹气）我很难哭出来。对我来说哭是非常困难的。在睾酮之前，如果我沮丧、愤怒或难过，痛哭一场会很棒。之后你会感觉好些。我也确实在想这背后是不是有化学成分在作祟。因为我现在很难做到。这非常令人沮丧。
And what I will do is, when I feel that pressure build up, I'll go into my room. I'll close the door and force myself. I have to force myself to cry. And the quality of the crying is different than the quality of the crying was before T. It's very dry. I find myself sort of moaning and sobbing but with very little tears.
我会做的是，当感到那种压力积聚时，我会走进房间。关上门，强迫自己。我必须强迫自己哭。而这种哭泣的质感与T之前是不同的。非常干涩。我发现自己发出呻吟和抽泣，但几乎没有眼泪。
You have answered a lot of questions for us today.
你今天为我们回答了很多问题。
[LAUGHTER]
（大笑）
And reinforced a lot of stereotypes that we've almost disspelled with.
并且强化了许多我们几乎已经消除的刻板印象。
I know.
我知道。
[LAUGHTER]
（大笑）
I know I have. I know it.
我知道我强化了。我知道。
Did you have an idea of what kind of man you were going to be before the transition; this is my model?
你在转变之前对你想成为什么样的男人有概念吗；这是我的榜样？
Yeah.
是的。
What was it?
那是什么？
I used to watch a lot of Beverly Hills 90210. And Jason Priestley was my ideal, at least physically. I wanted sideburns so bad. And that was the first facial hair that came in. I got these beautiful sideburns. So it was sort of like the James Dean, Jason Priestley kind of model, I think. That didn't quite materialize. I was better at that as a dyke than I am as a man, I have to say.
我以前经常看《飞越比佛利》。杰森·普里斯特利是我的偶像，至少在身体上。我太想要鬓角了。那是第一批长出来的面部毛发。我长出了这些漂亮的鬓角。所以我觉得那就像是詹姆斯·迪恩、杰森·普里斯特利那种模式。那并没有完全实现。我必须说，我作为女同性恋时比现在作为男人时更像那种样子。
[LAUGHS]
（大笑）
And how do you feel about that?
你对此感觉如何？
It's a bit of a disappointment. It's a bit of a disappointment. I often ask people, what kind of a guy am I? What do you see? And unfortunately, people often respond that they see a nerd, which I never was before. I was always really kind of cool and popular and hip and whatever. And now I'm 5 foot 4. And I work out, but I'm not real muscular. And I'm pretty small.
有点失望。确实有点失望。我经常问别人，我算是个什么样的男人？你看到了什么？不幸的是，人们常回答说他们看到了一个书呆子，而我以前从来都不是。我以前总是那种挺酷、受欢迎、时髦之类的人。而现在我身高5英尺4英寸。我健身，但我不怎么强壮。而且我很瘦小。
I'm pale skinned. And my hair is starting to thin. And I've got glasses. And of course, I'm also a sensitive guy now. I used to be the butch dyke. And I was seen as very aggressive. And I was more masculine in many ways, outwardly, anyway, before testosterone. And now I don't have to prove anything. So I can lay back and talk with my hands and all that stuff that you're not supposed to do.
我皮肤苍白。头发开始变稀疏。我还戴眼镜。当然，我现在也是个敏感的男人。我曾经是那个硬朗的女同志。我被视为非常激进。而且在睾酮之前，无论如何，在外在方面我更具男性气概。而现在我不需要证明什么。所以我可以放松下来，用手势说话，以及所有那些被认为不该做的事情。
So I'm still very much learning how to be a man in the world. There's a lot to learn. Men-- walking the street is a constant battle. It's a constant contest.
所以我仍然在学习如何在世界上做一个男人。要学的东西很多。男人——走在街上是一场不断的战斗。是一场持续的竞赛。
I began to notice, once I started to pass as a man, that single men walking alone down the street will veer away from their path to walk towards me, get in my space, and then veer back. And it's very much like a little aggressive move. I've had men, just angry guys, walking on the street, just body check me. So I really feel like I have to sort of puff myself up so that people will keep their distance a little bit. But if I'm off guard and I'm walking around and I'm enjoying the scenery, it's pretty much guaranteed that somebody will shove me.
我开始注意到，一旦我开始被当作男人对待，独自走在街上的单身男人会偏离他们的路径向我走来，进入我的空间，然后又拐回去。这非常像是一种小小的攻击性行为。我遇到过一些愤怒的家伙走在街上，直接用身体撞我。所以我真的觉得我必须把自己的身体撑起来，让人们保持一点距离。但如果我不防备，四处闲逛享受风景，几乎可以保证会有人推我。
Were there specific things that you were hoping for?
有没有你特别期待的具体事情？
I think that the main thing that you hope for, that one hopes for, and that I hope for when starting testosterone, was to pass as male, to be perceived by the world as a man. But I do have a sort of love, hate relationship with passing, that my whole deeper self becomes invisible, and my history becomes invisible. And I think that's hard. It's a hard place to be.
我想，一个人期待的主要事情，一个人期待的，也是我开始服用睾酮时所期待的，就是被当作男性，被世界视为一个男人。但我对这种“被通过”有一种爱恨交织的关系，我的整个更深层的自我变得隐形了，我的历史变得隐形了。我认为那很艰难。那是一个艰难的境地。
Right, right.
没错，没错。
Especially because, when I got my first job as a man, they didn't know anything about my past. It was very corporate. So I had to let go of any edgy clothing and facial hair and whatnot that I had before. And I became really boring. I felt like, wow, people must think I'm really boring. If they only knew that I'm so fascinating.
尤其是因为，当我作为男人找到第一份工作时，他们对我的过去一无所知。那是非常企业化的。所以我不得不放弃我之前所有的那种前卫的装束和面部毛发之类的。我变得非常无聊。我觉得，哇，人们一定认为我真的很无聊。如果他们知道我其实如此迷人就好了。
[LAUGHTER]
（大笑）
Throughout those almost four years, I had to conceal a lot. I would lie about where I went to college, because I went to Bryn Mawr. And I couldn't say I went to Bryn Mawr.
在那近四年里，我不得不隐瞒很多东西。我会对我在哪上的大学撒谎，因为我上了布林茅尔学院。我不能说我上了布林茅尔。
What college did you say you went to?
你说你上了什么大学？
[CHUCKLES] Well, Bryn Mawr is in the bi-college relationship with Haverford College. And so I would say I went to Haverford, which is kind of-- I don't want to say anything bad about Haverford. Some of my best friends went there.
（轻笑）好吧，布林茅尔和哈弗福德学院有双校关系。所以我通常会说我上了哈弗福德，这算是——我不想说哈弗福德的坏话。我最好的朋友中有些人就在那儿上的学。
But I think Bryn Mawr is a superior school to Haverford. I do. And I think it's a superior education. And when I have to say I went to Haverford, it's like a little knife in my heart.
但我认为布林茅尔是一所比哈弗福德更好的学校。我确实这么认为。我认为这是一种更好的教育。当我不得不说我上了哈弗福德时，就像心口被扎了一刀。
[LAUGHTER]
（大笑）
But no offense to my Haverford friends.
不过，不冒犯我的哈弗福德朋友。
[LAUGHS] What do you feel the biggest thing that you do miss is?
（大笑）你觉得你最怀念的最大的一件事是什么？
Hmm. Maybe the close relationships that I had with women. I still have close relationships with the women I've known since before T. But I don't make close relationships with new female friends. It's hard to do. There's a barrier.
嗯。也许是我和女性之间曾经的亲密关系。我和在T之前就认识的女性仍然保持着亲密关系。但我不会和新的女性朋友建立亲密关系了。这很难做到。有一道隔阂。
So I kind of miss being part of a cool bunch of women. I actually like women better than men. It just so happens that I fit in more as a man. But I think women are really cool. Sisterhood is powerful, all that stuff.
所以我有点怀念曾经是一个很酷的女性群体的一部分。其实比起男人，我更喜欢女人。只是碰巧我作为男人更合群。但我认为女人真的很酷。姐妹情谊是强大的，诸如此类。
[CHUCKLES] Yeah. Yeah. And what do you think is the biggest thing you've gained?
（轻笑）是啊。是啊。那你认为你获得的最大的一件事是什么？
Biggest thing I've gained-- it's just so great when people call me sir. Even after seven years, I don't always hear it. But it still rings a little bell inside my heart-- like, oh, sir. It's wonderful. And it's something that, when I was a little kid, I used to wish for. Turn me into a boy-- Pinocchio. And you never really think it's possible. But it is possible.
获得的最大的一件事——当人们叫我“先生”时感觉真是太好了。即使七年过去了，我并不总是能听到它。但它依然在我心中敲响了一点小钟——就像，噢，先生。这太美妙了。这是我小时候曾向往的事情。把我变成男孩——匹诺曹。你从来没真正想过那会成为可能。但它确实可能。
And the other nice thing about it is, knowing that that's possible, that you can actually make this enormous leap means that, well, then anything else must be possible, too. Because this is certainly unbelievable.
而关于它的另一件美妙的事情是，知道那是有可能的，你可以真正跨出这巨大的一步，这意味着，嗯，那么其他任何事情也一定是有可能的。因为这绝对是不可思议的。
Griffin Hansbury is a psychoanalyst and the author of the novel, Some Strange Music Draws Me In. That conversation with Alex Blumberg happened over 20 years ago during his early transition back in 2002. When we reached out to him today, he told us that he would describe some of these experiences differently now, the way he talked about gender and also the way he talked about looking at women's bodies.
格里芬·汉斯伯里是一位心理分析学家，也是小说《有些奇怪的音乐吸引我》的作者。那次与亚历克斯·布隆伯格的谈话发生在20多年前他早期转变期间的2002年。当我们今天与他取得联系时，他告诉我们，他现在会以不同的方式描述其中一些经历，包括他谈论性别的方式，以及他谈论凝视女性身体的方式。
In retrospect, he says, it wasn't just the testosterone affecting him when he was looking at women. He says he'd also absorbed a lot of very traditional messages about masculinity. Overall, he said, he wouldn't want listeners to come away thinking that testosterone by itself explains so much about men's relationships with women and so much about desire.
回想起来，他说，当他凝视女性时，不仅仅是睾酮在影响他。他说他也吸收了许多关于男子气概的非常传统的信息。总的来说，他说，他不会希望听众认为睾酮本身就能解释关于男人与女人的关系以及欲望的那么多事情。
[MUSIC - "TO SIR WITH LOVE" BY LULU]
（音乐——露露演唱的《给先生的爱》）
Coming up, who has the most testosterone, the slightly femmy host of a public radio program, his staff, or a gay man in New York City? Answer in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，谁的睾酮水平最高，是公共电台节目中那个有点女性化的主持人，他的员工，还是纽约的一位男同性恋？一分钟后，当我们的节目继续时，芝加哥公共电台将为您揭晓答案。
It's This American life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show is one that we're rerunning because of the news that Pete Hegseth is ordering everybody in the military over 30 years old to have their testosterone tested and offering extra testosterone to anybody who scores low. As I said at the beginning of the show, back in 2002, we did an episode where everyone in our workplace had their testosterone tested in an episode about testosterone and just how much testosterone determines our personalities and fates. We rejoin that episode now with Act 2 of the program. Act Two, Contest-osterone.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是我们因为皮特·赫格塞斯下令要求军中所有30岁以上的人员进行睾酮检测，并为得分低的人提供额外睾酮的新闻而重播的。正如我在节目开头所说，2002年，我们做了一集节目，让我们工作场所的所有人都进行了睾酮检测，这是一集关于睾酮以及睾酮在多大程度上决定了我们的人格和命运的节目。我们现在接着那集节目的第二幕。第二幕，比赛睾酮。
At some point in putting together this week's radio show, Alex, who you heard a lot of in the first half of our program, suggested that it might be a fun thing to do and might illustrate some interesting principles about testosterone if everybody on the radio staff would get their testosterone level checked. We could each predict who would come out as number one, number two, and so forth based on their personalities. And then we would compare the results with what each of us had predicted.
在制作本周广播节目时，你在前半段节目中听到了很多关于亚历克斯的话，他建议说，如果电台的全体员工都能检查一下睾酮水平，可能会很有趣，并能阐明一些关于睾酮的有趣原理。我们可以根据每个人的个性预测谁会是第一名、第二名，以此类推。然后我们将结果与我们每个人的预测进行比较。
Since men always have a lot more testosterone than women, we would do two rankings, one for men, one for the women. We invited two of our regular contributors, David Rakoff and Sarah Vowell, to take part with us, making it five men and four women in all. It turns out to be remarkably easy to get your testosterone assessed. You spit into a little tube twice a day and send it to a lab-- in our case, the Yerkes National Primate Research Center.
因为男性的睾酮总是比女性多得多，所以我们进行了两项排名，一项针对男性，一项针对女性。我们邀请了我们两位常驻撰稿人大卫·拉科夫和萨拉·沃威尔参与，总共有五名男性和四名女性。事实证明，评估你的睾酮水平非常简单。你每天往一个小试管里吐两次口水，然后寄给实验室——在我们的案例中，是耶克斯国家灵长类动物研究中心。
And I think it was Jonathan and Starlee, producers on our show, who you sometimes hear doing stories on the air, who pointed out first that the entire enterprise might not be such a good idea.
我想是我们节目的制片人乔纳森和斯塔莉，你有时会听到他们在广播中做报道，首先指出整个企业可能不是一个好主意。
I just think we're opening a whole can of worms here that we don't want to be doing.
我只是觉得我们在这里开启了一个我们不想触碰的潘多拉魔盒。
This whole thing is kind of a mess, diplomatic-wise.
从外交角度看，这整个事情真是一团糟。
How so?
怎么讲？
Either we'll walk away from this finding out that Starlee has more testosterone than I do, and she'll end up being incredibly upset, and I'll be upset, and everyone will just be upset. You know? I mean, what do we hope to gain, really, from all of this? This whole thing is going to lead to heartbreak somehow.
要么我们最后发现斯塔莉的睾酮比我的还多，她会变得非常心烦，我也会心烦，每个人都会心烦。你知道吗？我的意思是，我们到底能从中获得什么呢？这整件事最终会以心碎告终。
I've been thinking a lot about it. And I can't really decide whether I want to have more or if I want to have less.
我一直在思考这个问题。我真的无法决定我想要更多还是更少。
This is Wendy, another producer.
这是温迪，另一位制片人。
I don't know. Having more makes me seem like an [BLEEP].
我不知道。拥有更多让我看起来像个混蛋。
[LAUGHTER]
（大笑）
And having not enough makes me seem like a pushover, sucker.
而不够多让我看起来像个软蛋，倒霉鬼。
For the men, I think it'll be a big deal.
对于男性来说，我认为这将是一件大事。
This is Julie, the senior producer of our program.
这是朱莉，我们节目的高级制片人。
I think it'll change all your interactions with each other. You'll know, when you're talking to each other, who beat you. I think it'll change everything.
我想这会改变你们彼此之间所有的互动。当你们交谈时，你们会知道谁赢了你。我想这会改变一切。
Nonetheless, we marched toward the abyss. To find out what personality traits actually correlate with high testosterone and low testosterone, we checked with somebody who's done a lot of research on the subject, James Dabbs of Georgia State University, author of a book called Heroes, Rogues, and Lovers-- Testosterone and Behavior.
尽管如此，我们还是走向了深渊。为了找出什么样的人格特质实际上与高睾酮和低睾酮相关，我们咨询了一位在这一领域做了大量研究的人，佐治亚州立大学的詹姆斯·达布斯，他是《英雄、无赖和爱人——睾酮与行为》一书的作者。
The most simple thing I would say is it leads to a certain boldness and fearlessness and confidence in a person's behavior. They tend to focus upon what they do, move forward with less conflict. The downside is they don't pay attention to things going on around them, so they get blindsided by accidents and other things going on.
最简单的话说，它会导致一种行为上的大胆、无畏和自信。他们倾向于专注于他们所做的事情，减少冲突地向前推进。缺点是他们不关注周围发生的事情，所以他们会被意外和其他事情弄得措手不及。
What are some of the misconceptions you run into?
你遇到的一些误解是什么？
Well, they think it makes them manly and heroic and virile and sexual, which is not really true. It doesn't take much testosterone to have sex. So that's beside the point.
嗯，他们认为这使他们显得更有男子气概、更英勇、更有活力、更有性吸引力，这其实并不完全正确。性行为并不需要多少睾酮。所以那是不相关的。
What scientific studies can tell us is that, in general, more testosterone does not mean you're a more successful person. In fact, blue collar workers tend to have more testosterone than white collar workers. And unemployed men have more than either group.
科学研究能告诉我们的是，通常情况下，睾酮越多并不意味着你是一个更成功的人。事实上，蓝领工人的睾酮往往比白领工人多。而失业男性的睾酮比这两组人都多。
Actors and trial lawyers, people who basically go on stage in one way or another, tend to have very high testosterone levels. Higher testosterone correlates with baldness and with bigger muscles. And researchers say that people with lots of testosterone have a wolfish smile. And people with less testosterone have a kinder smile. And they smile more often, as if to say, don't hurt me.
演员和出庭律师，那些基本上以某种方式登台的人，往往有非常高的睾酮水平。高睾酮与秃顶和更大的肌肉相关。研究人员说，睾酮水平高的人有狼性的微笑。而睾酮水平低的人有更友善的微笑。而且他们笑得更频繁，仿佛在说，别伤害我。
Testosterone goes up when you score a victory at something. It goes down when you suffer a defeat. In one study of World Cup soccer fans watching a match on television, testosterone dropped in fans of the losing team and rose in the fans of the winning team.
当你在某事上取得胜利时，睾酮会上升。当你遭受失败时，它会下降。在一项针对观看电视比赛的世界杯足球迷的研究中，输球一方球迷的睾酮下降了，赢球一方球迷的睾酮上升了。
For people, there's not a lot of difference between being in the contest and watching the contest. We can empathize with it so well.
对于人们来说，参与比赛和观看比赛并没有太大的区别。我们可以很好地感同身受。
So what would all this mean for our radio staff? Well, when it came to predicting which of the women would have the highest testosterone, there was a clear majority in the voting. Here are Sarah Vowell, Todd, our production manager, and Wendy weighing in.
那么这一切对我们的电台员工意味着什么呢？嗯，当预测哪位女性睾酮水平最高时，投票中出现了明显的大多数。这是萨拉·沃威尔、我们的制作经理托德和温迪的看法。
Julie will win.
朱莉会赢。
Julie's tough. She can certainly push me around sometimes.
朱莉很强悍。她有时确实能随便摆布我。
I think Julie has the most, because she is the boldest of all of us. She says the boldest things.
我觉得朱莉最高，因为她是我们在场所有人中最胆大的。她说的都是最大胆的话。
When we're all together in the same place, it is clearly Julie who is the alpha of the whole group. Though, at some point in putting together this week's radio show, Alex and Julie sat down in his studio. And he asked her to predict which women would have the highest testosterone. And here's how she lined it up.
当我们都在同一个地方时，朱莉显然是整个团体的领头羊。不过，在制作本周广播节目时，亚历克斯和朱莉坐在他的演播室里。他让她预测哪位女性会有最高的睾酮。以下是她的排序方式。
Wendy first and then Starlee and then Sarah, I guess.
先是温迪，然后是斯塔莉，然后是萨拉，我想。
And then?
然后呢？
And then me, just passive me, just taking it easy, girly, girly me just being feminine over here in the corner. Honestly, who do I think?
然后是我，就我这个消极的我，轻轻松松， girly，girly的我，在角落里展现女性气质。说实话，我自己觉得会是谁？
Yeah.
是啊。
Well, I fear, me.
嗯，我担心是我自己。
What do you think it would mean if you won?
你觉得如果你赢了意味着什么？
Well, then it would confirm all my worst suspicions about myself, that I'm really aggressive and pushy and sort of a hothead. I fear, me.
好吧，那会证实我对自己的所有最糟糕的怀疑，即我真的很激进、咄咄逼人，是个容易冲动的人。我担心是我。
Among the men, there was no favorite. You could kind of make an argument for any of the men on the staff. Todd likes sports, and he isn't such a bookworm softy like the rest of us on the staff. Alex plays a lot of sports and he gets into fights on the basketball court. Jonathan is balding and he has a lot of muscle-- corresponds with testosterone.
在男性中，没有明显的赢家。你可以为员工中的任何男性提出论点。托德喜欢运动，他不像我们其他员工那样是个书呆子软蛋。亚历克斯喜欢运动，他在篮球场上会打架。乔纳森秃顶，肌肉发达——这与睾酮相关。
I host a national radio show, which must count for something, right? But when we sat down to talk about it, it wasn't really clear exactly what else should be taken into account. Here's Jonathan.
我主持一个全国性的广播节目，这肯定算点什么，对吧？但当我们坐下来讨论时，并不清楚到底还有什么应该考虑在内。这是乔纳森。
I don't entirely understand how this whole testosterone thing works. It's like, who can yell the loudest. Who has the most rage? I have rage. Unfortunately, it's, like, impotent rage. And I don't know that's going to rank.
我不完全理解这整个睾酮的东西是如何运作的。就像，谁能吼得最大声。谁有最大的愤怒？我有愤怒。不幸的是，那就像是无能的狂怒。我不知道那会如何排名。
And then, if the main thing the testosterone corresponds with is decisiveness, how does that swing the whole rating?
而且，如果睾酮主要对应的东西是果断性，那么这会如何左右整个评级呢？
I didn't realize that the whole decision making thing came into this whole testosterone thing. Yeah, it's really more complicated.
我没意识到整个决策的事情也包含在这个睾酮的东西里。是啊，它真的更复杂。
Reevaluate?
重新评估？
Yeah, because I'm just filled with regret.
是啊，因为我心里充满了遗憾。
Again, Julie, quick decisions, doesn't look back.
再次强调，朱莉，决策快，从不回头。
That's very true.
那是真的。
I know-- same with Sarah.
我知道——萨拉也一样。
I look back like I'm looking--
我回头看就像我在看——
I look back pretty much every single--
我几乎在每一件事上都回头看——
Every single second of the day. Every single-- I'm regretting what I'm saying right now. Yeah.
每一秒钟。每一件——我现在正在后悔我所说的话。是啊。
I'm filled with regret. Here we go.
我充满了遗憾。开始了。
[LAUGHTER]
（大笑）
You're regretting it even as you're saying it.
你甚至在说话的时候就在后悔。
Even now, even now, even now.
即便是现在，即便是现在，即便是现在。
[LAUGHTER]
（大笑）
And then there's the question of David Rakoff. He's gay and a fan of Martha Stewart. But he's also balding, and he's worked as a professional actor, which both correspond with high testosterone levels. So how do you figure that one out?
还有大卫·拉科夫的问题。他是同性恋，也是玛莎·斯图尔特的粉丝。但他也在秃顶，并且做过职业演员，这两者都与高睾酮水平相关。那你怎么想出这个问题的呢？
The one thing I do worry about the testosterone is Alex told me, when I did my spit, that I had to have some extra spearmint gum to activate my salivary glands. But the only thing that I could find was Extra Polar Ice, which has flavor crystals. And I worry that my sample might have flavor crystals in it.
关于睾酮我确实担心的唯一一件事是，亚历克斯在我做口水采样时告诉我，我必须吃一些额外的绿薄荷口香糖来激活我的唾液腺。但我能找到的唯一东西是 Extra Polar Ice，它含有调味晶体。我担心我的样本里可能含有调味晶体。
[LAUGHTER]
（大笑）
So in fact, I might just simply be the most refreshing.
所以事实上，我可能仅仅是最清爽的那一个。
[LAUGHTER]
（大笑）
One notable difference between the men and the women-- although none of the women wanted to have much testosterone, Alex, Todd, and I very, very much wanted to win. Jonathan claimed he did not want to win, but none of us believe him. And Rakoff also said that he had no interest in winning at all but then proceeded immediately-- I mean, immediately-- to talk smack about his opponents in a very competitive way. And that was the state of things when we got our results from the lab just two days ago.
男性和女性之间的一个显著差异是——尽管没有女性想要拥有太多睾酮，亚历克斯、托德和我非常、非常想赢。乔纳森声称他不想赢，但我们都不信他。拉科夫也说他根本没兴趣赢，但随后立即——我的意思是，立即——以一种非常有竞争力的方式对他的对手进行嘲讽。这就是我们两天前从实验室得到结果时的状况。
All right, well, it is two days before our broadcast day. As I record this, our entire staff is on mic, plus contributors, David Rakoff and Sarah Vowell in New York. Hello, all.
好的，好吧，距离我们的广播日还有两天。当我录制这段录音时，我们全体员工都在麦克风前，加上撰稿人大卫·拉科夫和萨拉·沃威尔在纽约。大家好。
Hello.
大家好。
Hi.
嗨。
And now for the results, I am opening the envelope. Wow, that's fascinating.
现在公布结果，我正在拆开信封。哇，真令人着迷。
[LAUGHTER]
（大笑）
Wow, that's just incredible. OK, among the men, Rakoff is number one and has twice the amount of testosterone of anybody in the group.
哇，真是太不可思议了。好的，在男性中，拉科夫是第一名，睾酮含量是组里其他人的两倍。
Woo!
呜！
[LAUGHTER]
（大笑）
Wow.
哇。
This can't be correct.
这不可能正确。
I told you.
我告诉过你们。
Correlation with baldness.
与秃顶的相关性。
I voted for you, Rakoff.
我投票投给了你，拉科夫。
Oh, everybody's trying to get in with him now that he's number one.
哦，每个人都在他成为第一名后试图和他套近乎。
[LAUGHTER]
（大笑）
Then in order, the men are-- it's Rakoff, then Alex at number two, then me, like, a point behind you, Alex, then Jonathan and then Todd-- all very closely grouped together.
然后按顺序，男性是——拉科夫，然后亚历克斯第二名，然后是我，比你亚历克斯低一点，然后是乔纳森，然后是托德——所有人都非常接近。
Wow, but Rakoff has twice as much.
哇，但是拉科夫拥有两倍之多。
As any of us, the gay, Canadian Jew living in Manhattan.
比我们任何人都多，那个生活在曼哈顿的加拿大犹太同性恋。
OK, we really have to dispense with the Canadian. Actually, that is non-corollary. Believe me.
好的，我们真的必须省去那个加拿大人的说法。实际上，那是非相关性的。相信我。
[LAUGHTER]
（大笑）
What are the numbers exactly? What's Rakoff?
具体的数字是多少？拉科夫是多少？
Rakoff is 274. You're 144. I'm one hundred for--.
拉科夫是274。你是144。我是104——。
Oh, my God!
天哪！
[LAUGHTER]
（大笑）
When I looked at the women's results in the envelope, even though she is seven months pregnant, Julie was on top, as we all suspected.
当我看到信封里女性的结果时，尽管她怀孕七个月了，朱莉还是第一名，正如我们所有人怀疑的那样。
[LAUGHING] Well, it's hard. It's hard. It makes me feel really bossy and aggressive. Now, did they say that the pregnancy would affect it at all?
（大笑）嗯，很难。很难。它让我觉得真的很爱发号施令，咄咄逼人。现在，他们有没有说怀孕会影响它？
She says, trying to make sure you get in that whole girly pregnancy thing.
她说，试图确保你在这个整个girly的怀孕事情上跟上。
Yeah, the fact that I'm able to bear children.
是啊，我能生育孩子的事实。
[LAUGHTER]
（大笑）
The greatest gift a woman can have.
女人能拥有的最伟大的礼物。
[LAUGHTER]
（大笑）
I have to say, Wendy and Todd, the lowest-scoring woman and man on the staff, really did not seem very happy about this whole thing by the end. Todd, like most of the men on the staff, had never been seen as especially manly during his life. But he thought maybe here, maybe here in this group, compared to the rest of us, he might at least stand a chance.
我不得不说，温迪和托德，员工中得分最低的女性和男性，到最后看起来对整件事并没有那么高兴。托德，像电台的大多数男性员工一样，一生中从未被视为特别有男人味。但他想也许在这里，也许在这个群体中，与我们其他人相比，他至少可能有一线希望。
Someone would be girlier than I. If I can't be the most manly in public radio, where the hell can I be the most manly? I kind of wish this was SportsCenter, because then I'd be OK. Out of all my fellow staff members at SportsCenter, OK, I could be the one with the least testosterone. But in public radio--
有人会比我更girly。如果我在公共电台不能成为最有男人味的，我在哪儿能成为最有男人味的？我真希望这是《体育中心》，因为那样我就没问题了。在《体育中心》的所有同事中，好的，我可以是睾酮最少的那一个。但在公共电台——
We should get them to spit. Is it a real place, SportsCenter? Is that a thing?
我们应该让他们吐口水。那是个真实的地方吗，《体育中心》？那是个东西吗？
Now, see, that's not fair. How can he have the most testosterone and not know what SportsCenter is? I know what SportsCenter is!
现在，看，那不公平。他怎么能拥有最多的睾酮却不知道《体育中心》是什么？我知道《体育中心》是什么！
The people in our staff who scored low are feeling rather terrible about it. What should I say to them?
我们员工中得分低的人感觉很糟糕。我该对他们说什么？
I hated to measure them. I just knew that would happen. It always happens. I told them that. Tell them, well, they are what they are. Are they in any way different?
我讨厌去测量他们。我早就知道会发生那样的事。它总是发生。我告诉过他们。告诉他们，嗯，他们就是他们。他们有任何不同吗？
After our test, James Dabbs reminded me that it was important to remember that any individual person might not conform to the stereotypes of who has higher testosterone. It's not the final answer as to what you're like.
测试结束后，詹姆斯·达布斯提醒我，重要的是要记住，任何个人都可能不符合关于谁拥有更高睾酮的刻板印象。这不是你是什么样的最终答案。
I've tested a stunt man in a movie set once. And he came out low in testosterone and was terribly unhappy about being low in testosterone. The fact is, he still was a stuntman and did all the work that other people couldn't do. So he shouldn't have been focusing upon that testosterone. I think to focus upon the testosterone is the wrong thing to do.
我曾经在电影拍摄现场测试过一个特技演员。他的睾酮水平很低，对自己睾酮水平低非常不开心。事实上，他仍然是个特技演员，做了其他人做不了的工作。所以他不应该专注于那个睾酮。我认为专注于睾酮是做错事了。
Now when you tried to convince him that he shouldn't feel bad about it, did he find that persuasive at all?
当你试图说服他不要为之感到难过时，他觉得有说服力吗？
No, no, he was just unhappy.
不，不，他只是不开心。
James Dabbs-- I mentioned before that this is a rerun from years ago. In the years since we first broadcast this, James Dabbs has died. Our friend, David Rakoff, has died, too, back in 2012.
詹姆斯·达布斯——我之前提到过这是多年前的重播。在我们首次播出这个节目后的几年里，詹姆斯·达布斯已经去世了。我们的朋友，大卫·拉科夫，也在2012年去世了。
[MUSIC - "WHAT KIND OF MAN ARE YOU" BY RAY CHARLES]
（音乐——雷·查尔斯演唱的《你算什么男人》）
Act Three, Life at Zero. OK, so a life with very low testosterone, what might that mean? Well, the most extreme case imaginable is described in the GQ article that Alex read that was one of the inspirations for today's show, that he talked about at the beginning of the program. The GQ writer very much describes testosterone as the hormone of desire.
第三幕，零度生活。好的，那么睾酮非常低的生活可能意味着什么？嗯，亚历克斯读的那篇《GQ》文章里描述了可以想象的最极端的案例，那是今天节目灵感的来源之一，他在节目开头谈到了这一点。《GQ》作者非常多地将睾酮描述为欲望的荷尔蒙。
And by that, he doesn't mean sexual desire. He just means desire, period. He wrote about his experiences anonymously. Here's more of Alex's interview with him.
通过这一点，他指的不是性欲。他指的只是欲望，仅此而已。他匿名写下了他的经历。以下是亚历克斯对他的更多采访。
When you have no testosterone, you have no desire. And when you have no desire, you don't have any content in your mind. You don't think about anything.
当你没有睾酮时，你没有欲望。当你没有欲望时，你脑子里没有任何内容。你什么都不想。
And during those months, how were you behaving? What was different?
在那几个月里，你的行为如何？有什么不同？
It wasn't that I was behaving. It was that I was not behaving at all. I was, when I was awake, literally sitting in bed and staring at the wall with neither interest nor disinterest for three, four hours at a time. If you'd had a camera in the room, you would have thought I was comatose. I would go out. I would buy some groceries early in the morning. And that would be it. My day had no content.
不是我的行为如何。而是我根本没有任何行为。当我是醒着的时候，字面意思就是坐在床上盯着墙看，三、四个小时，既没有兴趣也没有没兴趣。如果你在房间里放个摄像头，你会以为我处于昏迷状态。我会出去。我会在清晨买点杂货。那样就结束了。我的日子没有任何内容。
I had no interest in even watching TV, much less reading the newspaper or a book. Food-- I didn't want my food to taste good or interesting. And when you're blessed with that lack of desire, you can eat a loaf of Wonder Bread with mayonnaise. And that will be your day.
我甚至对看电视没有兴趣，更别说读报纸或书了。食物——我不想让我的食物尝起来美味或有趣。当你被那种缺乏欲望所祝福时，你可以吃一整条加了蛋黄酱的Wonder面包。而那就会是你的一天。
And I only saw my girlfriend on weekends, since she was living in New York and I was living in Philly. So I could get away with it five days at a time. And needless to say, there was absolutely no desire.
我只在周末见到我的女朋友，因为她住在纽约，我住在费城。所以我可以一次瞒过她五天。不用说，完全没有欲望。
People who are deprived of testosterone don't become Spock-like and incredibly rational. They become nonsensical, because they're unable to distinguish between what is and isn't interesting and what is worth noting and what isn't.
缺乏睾酮的人不会变得像史波克那样极其理性。他们会变得毫无逻辑，因为他们无法区分什么是感兴趣的，什么不是，什么值得注意，什么不是。
Describe your thoughts on your morning walk in this state.
描述一下你在那种状态下晨间散步的想法。
It's very quiet at 5:30, 6:00, 6:30 in the morning. And I would see a brick in a wall, and I would think, a brick in a wall. I would see a pigeon and think, a pigeon. It's the most literal possible understanding of the world.
清晨5:30、6:00、6:30很安静。我会看到墙上的一块砖，我会想，墙上的一块砖。我会看到一只鸽子，心想，一只鸽子。这是对世界最字面意义上的理解。
So in this time when you're without testosterone, when you're walking down the street, you're just sort of ticking things off, just making these very simple observations.
所以在你没有睾酮的这段时间，当你走在街上时，你只是在罗列事物，只是在做这些非常简单的观察。
Like a grocery list.
就像购物清单。
Yeah, like a grocery list. Exactly. You also have a thought that comes to you all the time, right?
是啊，就像购物清单。没错。你还有一个一直出现在你脑海里的想法，对吧？
Yeah.
是啊。
Talk about that.
谈谈那个。
Which is a very strange sounding thing, which is that is beautiful. Everything I saw, I thought, that is beautiful, which is odd sounding, I know. Because that sounds like the judgment of a person with passion.
这是一个听起来非常奇怪的事情，那就是“那很美”。我看到的一切，我都会想，那很美，这听起来很奇怪，我知道。因为那听起来像是一个充满激情的人的评判。
But it was the exact opposite. It was thought and sometimes even said with complete dispassion, with objectivity. And you see, I was looking at absolutely everything, the most mundane sight in the world-- a weed in the sidewalk-- and thinking, oh, that's beautiful. The surgery scars on people's knees, the bolts in the hubcaps of cars, all of it, it just seemed to have purpose. And it was like, oh, that's beautiful.
但那完全相反。那是思想，有时甚至是以完全客观、没有激情的方式说出来的。你看，我在看绝对的一切，世界上最平凡的景象——人行道上的一棵杂草——心想，噢，那很美。人们膝盖上的手术疤痕，汽车轮毂盖上的螺栓，所有这些，看起来似乎都有目的。就像是，噢，那很美。
Everything is beautiful, from the bugs to the cracks in the sidewalk, to the faces of other people. And it was automatic. Perhaps, to see things objectively is to see them, all of them, as beautiful.
一切都很美，从虫子到人行道上的裂缝，再到其他人的脸。而且那是自动的。也许，客观地看待事物就是看待它们，全部，并将它们视为美丽的。
But you have to understand that the thought was expressed in the most flat line, boring way possible. Oh, yeah, that's beautiful. That's beautiful.
但你必须明白，这个想法是以最平淡、最无聊的方式表达出来的。噢，是啊，那很美。那很美。
You would think that this would be a terrible thing, a terrible state to be in. And for most people, it is. But it was weirdly pleasant. And there is a certain appeal, an impossible appeal, to that Rip Van Winkle existence of being without testosterone.
你会认为这会是一件可怕的事情，一种可怕的状态。对于大多数人来说，确实如此。但它离奇地令人愉快。而且那种没有睾酮的“里普·凡·温克尔”式的存在，有一种某种吸引力，一种不可能的吸引力。
You just have to remember that it doesn't matter if you have nothing if you want nothing. It's very tricky to get inside that mindset. In some ways, it's difficult for me to even remember it now. But it had its allure.
你只需要记住，如果你什么都不想要，那么拥有一无所有也就不重要了。要进入那种思维方式非常棘手。在某种程度上，我现在甚至很难记住它。但它有它的诱惑力。
Well, I can understand that. Because desire often feels like a burden. It often feels like, if I just didn't want that thing, not having it wouldn't be so painful.
嗯，我可以理解。因为欲望通常让人感觉是一种负担。通常感觉是，如果我只是不想要那个东西，没有它就不会那么痛苦了。
There you go.
这就对了。
Yeah.
是啊。
All that wanting.
所有的渴望。
Act Four, Learning to Shut Up. OK, so we started today's program with my coworker, Alex, remembering what it was like to be a 15-year-old boy. And we're going to end it now with another 15-year-old boy, someone who's experiencing the years when a boy's body is flooded with 10 or 20 times the hormones he has in early childhood or more. And so much of the story is about his mother's questions about what it's like for him. His mom, Miriam Toews, tells the story.
第四幕，学会闭嘴。好的，我们今天节目的开头提到了我的同事亚历克斯，回忆他作为一个15岁男孩是什么样子。我们现在要以另一个15岁男孩来结束它，一个正在经历男孩身体被比幼儿期多出10到20倍甚至更多荷尔蒙淹没的时期。故事的很大一部分是关于他母亲对他的体验的种种疑问。他的母亲，米里亚姆·托维斯，讲述了这个故事。
First off, his hair is red and shaggy and longish. And he's pale and slim and 6 feet tall. Music is everything to him, which makes sense, because he's 15. I was 22 when he was born. I'd never had brothers or any close male relatives. And I'd always dreamed of having a brother or a son. The idea of having a boy in my family was strange and exotic.
首先，他的头发是红色的，蓬乱且略长。他皮肤苍白，身材苗条，身高6英尺。音乐对他来说就是一切，这很有道理，因为他才15岁。他出生时我22岁。我从未有过兄弟或任何亲近的男性亲戚。我一直梦想有个兄弟或儿子。家里有个男孩的想法对我来说既陌生又新奇。
When he was born, it was like I had given birth to a llama or something. All my girlfriends came to visit me and him in the hospital. And I took them down to the second floor nursery. And we stared at him in awe from behind a glass window. That's him, I said, with the orange fuzz on his head. He was lying naked and spread-eagled under a bright heat lamp. He seemed very content.
他出生时，就像我生了一只羊驼之类的东西。我所有的女朋友都来看望我和他在医院。我带她们下到二楼的新生儿室。我们从玻璃窗后敬畏地盯着他看。我说，那就是他，头上有橙色的绒毛。他赤身裸体地躺在一盏明亮的热灯下，叉着腿。他看起来非常满足。
My friend, Carol, gasped and said, oh, my God, he's got the biggest balls I've ever seen in my life. We all started laughing our heads off. And then the nurse came and told us his scrotum would shrink to normal size in a few days. I haven't seen him naked in years. But it still often feels, when I look at him, that I'm gazing at an odd creature from behind a glass.
我的朋友卡罗尔惊呼道，天哪，他有着我这辈子见过的最大的睾丸。我们都笑得前仰后合。然后护士过来告诉我们，他的阴囊几天内就会缩小到正常大小。我已经很多年没见他赤身裸体了。但当我看着他时，依然常常感觉，我是透过玻璃窗凝视着一个奇怪的生物。
So do you think about girls?
那么你会想女孩吗？
Yes.
是的。
And what do you think about them?
那你怎么想她们？
I don't know. Some of them are cool.
我不知道。其中一些很酷。
Yeah? So what makes them cool?
是啊？那么是什么让她们酷的？
I don't know.
我不知道。
All his life, Owen's been a quiet kid, not sullen, but just rather silent. When he was a baby and I'd be pushing him around in his stroller, people would stop and crouch down and talk to him and expect him to laugh and smile. And all he'd do was sigh and stare at them.
欧文从小就是一个安静的孩子，不是阴郁，只是相当沉默。当他还是个婴儿，我推着他的婴儿车四处走时，人们会停下来蹲下跟他说话，期待他大笑或微笑。而他只会叹气，盯着他们看。
When he got a little older and went over to his friends' places to play and it was time for him to go home, he just got up and walked right out the door to the car. He didn't say, hey, thanks for having me or next time we'll play at my place or even goodbye. We'd be driving home. And I'd be trying to explain to him that it seemed rude and that sometimes we just had to say certain things at certain times. It was polite and expected.
当他稍微长大一点，去朋友家玩，到了该回家的时候，他只是站起来径直走出门口去车上。他不会说，嘿，谢谢招待我，或者下次我们去我家玩，甚至连再见都不说。我们开车回家。我会试着向他解释这显得很粗鲁，有时我们必须在某些时候说某些话。这是礼貌的，也是被期待的。
He'd just sigh and nod and kick the dash or stick his head entirely out the window. But back then, I could kind of figure out what was going on in his head, even if he didn't come right out and say it. Like when he was three and he didn't want me to go out, instead of grabbing my leg or having a tantrum or something, he'd hide my shoes and then sit on the couch pretending to read the newspaper while I searched all over the place.
他只会叹气、点头，踢仪表盘或把头完全伸出窗外。但那时候，我还能搞清楚他脑子里在想什么，即使他没有直说。就像他三岁时不想让我出门，他不会抱住我的腿或耍脾气之类的，而是会藏起我的鞋子，然后坐在沙发上假装看报纸，而我则四处寻找。
When he was eight and angry and sitting in a tree and throwing stones at the car or something, I'd go outside, knowing it would be a matter of minutes before he'd start to cry and then slowly spill his guts about whatever series of events it was that led to his meltdown, and that the whole scene would end with hugs and apologies and probably a large muscle activity, like him cheerfully taking shots at my head with a soccer ball. Now, though, the signs are harder, if not impossible, to read. I'm not sure there are any, actually. And I had no idea where to begin my search.
他八岁时愤怒地坐在树上，向车扔石头之类的，我会走出去，知道只需几分钟他就会开始哭，然后慢慢倾诉导致他崩溃的一系列事件，整个场景会以拥抱、道歉和可能的大肌肉活动结束，比如他欢快地用足球朝我的头射门。然而现在，这些迹象更难读懂了，如果不是不可能的话。我不确定是否有迹象，其实。我也不知道从哪里开始我的搜寻。
What do you think girls think about you when they think about you?
你觉得女孩们想到你的时候会怎么想？
I don't know, nothing.
我不知道，没什么。
You think no girl ever thinks anything about you?
你认为没有女孩会想关于你的事吗？
Maybe. I don't know.
也许吧。我不知道。
He brought 85 CDs with him for a family road trip that would last 11 days. He also brought his sketchbook, which started out as an art class project and has since evolved into a kind of diary, I think. He tends to write things down, like, "Jesus, I got to find someone irrational or this [BLEEP] I'm passing off as writing is slowly killing me."
他带了85张CD进行一次持续11天的家庭公路旅行。他还带了他的素描本，那最初是一个美术课作业，后来演变成了一种日记，我想。他倾向于写下一些东西，比如，“天哪，我得找个理性的，否则我这冒充写作的狗屎正慢慢杀了我也。”
The first day of our road trip through North Dakota to South, the music war started. His 12-year-old sister, Georgia, claimed the very backseat of the minivan and was content to lie there surrounded by nail polish and beads and thread and Hershey Kisses and Archie comics and listen to her music on her Discman-- mostly R&B stuff, Destiny's Child and the Save the Last Dance soundtrack. My husband, Cassidy, and I sat in the front. And Owen sat on the seat right behind us so he could listen to his CDs on the stereo.
我们在北达科他州到南达科他州的公路旅行的第一天，音乐战争开始了。他12岁的妹妹乔治亚占领了微型面包车的最后排，满足地躺在那里，周围环绕着指甲油、珠子、线、好时之吻和阿奇漫画，用她的CD机听她的音乐——主要是R&B音乐，真命天女和《留住最后一支舞》的原声带。我的丈夫卡西迪和我坐在前排。欧文坐在我们身后的座位上，这样他就可以在立体声音响上听他的CD了。
We'd tell him to listen to them on his Discman, which he did sometimes. But then he'd miss out on our sporadic conversations, which he enjoyed either participating in or mocking. Sometimes he'd give us a choice of his CDs to play. Nirvana, he'd say. You guys like Nirvana, right?
我们会让他用CD机听，他有时会照做。但那样他就会错过我们偶尔的对话，他要么喜欢参与，要么喜欢嘲笑。有时他会给我们选择他的CD来播放。他会说，涅槃乐队。你们喜欢涅槃乐队，对吧？
Yeah, but the Unplugged one, we'd say. Oh, Lord, help me now, he'd say. He'd pop a dozen CDs into the player-- They Will Know Us by the Trail of Dead, Black Rebel Motorcycle Club, At the Drive In, other stuff. And we'd listen to half a song from each one and go, nope, nope, nope.
我们说，是啊，但那个不插电版的。他会说，噢，主啊，帮帮我吧。他会把十几张CD塞进播放器——死者足迹乐队、黑色叛逆摩托车俱乐部、车道乐队等等。我们会每张听半首歌，然后说，不，不，不。
I had wanted to learn more about him from his music. I was pretty sure his lyrics would tell me more about him than he would. But the problem was I couldn't understand most of the lyrics. And none of his CDs, which he'd bootlegged, had liner notes. We asked him if he didn't miss having liner notes. And he said, man, liner notes. You guys have this unnatural relationship with your liner notes.
我想通过他的音乐更多地了解他。我很确定他的歌词会比他自己更了解他。但问题是我听不懂大部分歌词。而且他盗版的CD一张都没有歌词内页。我们问他是否不怀念没有歌词内页。他说，伙计，歌词内页。你们对歌词内页有这种不自然的关系。
What are some of your favorite lyrics?
你最喜欢的一些歌词是什么？
Mm, I like some of the lyrics from the Pixies.
嗯，我喜欢小妖精乐队的一些歌词。
Can you say some of the lyrics from the Pixies?
你能说一下小妖精乐队的歌词吗？
"You're so pretty when you're unfaithful to me."
“当我背叛你时，你看起来真美。”
So what does that mean to you?
那对你意味着什么？
I don't know. I just thought it was funny.
我不知道。我只是觉得这很有趣。
When Owen was little, I discovered I could get him to do anything by timing him. Go get your jacket, I'd say, or clean up your toys quick. I'll time you. He loved competing with himself and beating his old records, even if I just made up times. And it evolved into a huge, competitive, sports-loving thing that I still don't really understand or enjoy. That timing thing didn't work at all with Georgia. She'd just look up at me and say, what do you mean, time me? What for?
欧文小的时候，我发现我可以通过计时让他做任何事。我说，去拿你的夹克，或者快点收拾玩具。我给你计时。他喜欢与自己竞争并打破自己的纪录，即使我只是编造时间。这演变成了一个巨大的、喜欢竞争、爱运动的事情，直到现在我仍然不太理解或享受。那种计时方法在乔治亚身上一点也不奏效。她只会抬头看着我说，你什么意思，给我计时？为了什么？
The difference between him and Georgia in the talking department is huge. Georgia will come home from school and literally reenact her entire day so that she's telling me about it almost in real time, hour after hour. Owen, on the other hand, might tell me that his day was good, even if it was bad. But usually, he just shrugs and makes an I don't know kind of sound. And then he'll head down to the basement and play his guitar.
他在说话方面和乔治亚的区别很大。乔治亚会从学校回家，字面意思上重演她的一整天，以至于她几乎在实时地告诉我，一小时接一小时。另一方面，欧文可能会告诉我他的一天过得不错，即使很糟糕。但通常，他只是耸耸肩，发出一种“我不知道”的声音。然后他会去地下室弹他的吉他。
So do some of your friends have girlfriends? And do you ever think that you'd like to have a girlfriend?
那么你的朋友中有女孩吗？你有没有想过你想要个女朋友？
Yeah.
是的。
What do you think they think? How would they describe you to their friends, do you think?
你觉得她们怎么想？你认为她们会怎么向她们的朋友描述你？
Mm. I don't know.
嗯。我不知道。
Do you think you do know, but you just don't really want to talk about it with me?
你认为你其实知道，只是你不想和我谈论这个吗？
I think that-- yeah, I think so.
我想那——是的，我想是这样。
I can dig it.
我能理解。
I've learned, over time, not to worry too much about his silence, although it used to drive me crazy. I wondered if maybe he'd turn out to be a psychopath. Although, I'm not sure why I associate evil with silence.
随着时间的推移，我学会了不要过多担心他的沉默，尽管那曾经让我发疯。我怀疑他是否最终会成为一个精神病患者。尽管我不确定为什么我会把邪恶与沉默联系起来。
Anyway, I'm getting better with it. Cassidy often reassures me by saying stuff like, it's a guy thing or he's a 15-year-old boy. What do you expect? He told me that, when he was Owen's age, he sat in his bedroom by himself for hours on end, typing page after page of angry vitriol against the world on an old manual typewriter, until his fingers bled. And he seems really happy now.
总之，我在这方面有所进步。卡西迪经常向我保证，说一些类似于“这是男人的事”或者“他是个15岁的男孩。你期待什么？”之类的话。他告诉我，当他像欧文那么大时，他独自坐在卧室里几个小时，在老式打字机上敲打着一页又一页对世界的愤怒抨击，直到手指流血。而他现在看起来很开心。
I realize my kids sound like boy and girl stereotypes. Owen is taciturn and into sports, and Georgia is chatty and prone to the occasional crying jag. But it really just is that way. I don't know why. It's not like we planned it. I don't want to think it's because he's a boy and she's a girl. But if it is, who cares? When Georgia was upset about something at school the other day and face down on the couch, he sat on the floor beside her and said, it's hard being a girl, isn't it?
我意识到我的孩子听起来像男孩和女孩的刻板印象。欧文沉默寡言且爱运动，乔治亚喋喋不休且偶尔容易大哭。但事实确实如此。我不知道为什么。这又不是我们计划好的。我不想认为这是因为他是男孩她是女孩。但如果是这样，那又怎样？前几天乔治亚在学校因为某事心烦意乱，趴在沙发上，他坐在她身边的地板上说，“做女孩很难，是吧？”
I'm not sure that it's any easier being a boy. And I don't know what he does exactly when he's sad, other than listening to music. Except for once, it's been years since I've seen him cry. I'd kill to read his notebook.
我不确定做男孩会更容易些。而且除了听音乐，我不知道他在难过时到底做了什么。除了有一次，我已经好几年没见他哭过了。我愿意做任何事来读读他的笔记本。
Is there anything about girls that you envy?
关于女孩有什么是你羡慕的吗？
No, nothing.
没有，什么都没有。
Nothing?
什么都没有？
Nothing.
什么都没有。
What about their-- it seems, their ability to talk about how they feel about things easier?
关于她们的——看起来，她们更容易谈论对事物的感受的能力？
Sure. Yeah.
当然。是啊。
You envy that?
你羡慕那个？
I definitely envy that.
我确实羡慕那个。
We were all pretty quiet as we drove up to Colorado Springs on our way to Denver. The sun was shining, but it was raining a bit. And we saw, not one, not two, but three dead cows in fields, stiff with their legs in the air. And it bothered us.
当我们开车去科罗拉多斯普林斯，在去丹佛的路上时，我们都很安静。阳光明媚，但下着点小雨。我们看到了不止一头，不是两头，而是三头死牛在田野里，四脚朝天僵硬着。这困扰着我们。
After the third dead cow, I played my favorite song of the summer, Gillian Welch's "Elvis Presley Blues." It's a wistful song about the King as a 15-year-old boy just starting out with a big rock-and-roll dream and a shirt his mother made. And it was kind of miraculous, because Owen actually liked it, too.
在第三头死牛之后，我播放了我夏天最喜欢的歌，吉莉安·韦尔奇的《埃尔维斯·普雷斯利的蓝调》。那是一首关于国王作为15岁男孩刚开始拥有巨大的摇滚梦和他母亲为他做的衬衫的忧伤歌曲。那简直是个奇迹，因为欧文竟然也喜欢它。
For me, it was a song about a boy becoming a man and leaving home. And it made me a little sad. I think Owen was probably hearing it as a song about a cool 15-year-old who was about to conquer the world. But really, I haven't got a clue how he heard the song or how it made him feel. All he said was that it had a decent pop sensibility. And then he was quiet.
对我来说，这是一首关于男孩长大成人离开家的歌。这让我有点难过。我想欧文听到的可能是一首关于一个即将征服世界的酷炫15岁男孩的歌。但真的，我完全不知道他是怎么听这首歌的，或者它让他有什么感觉。他只说它有不错的流行感。然后他就安静了。
These days, the more I press him for information, the faster he shuts right down. The other day, I tried a new approach-- his. I was annoyed by a bunch of things. And rather than broadcast it all over the house, I sat on the couch and glared at the TV and sighed periodically.
这些日子，我越是催促他获取信息，他关掉的速度就越快。前几天，我尝试了一种新方法——他的那种。我被一大堆事情搞得很烦。与其在屋子里到处广播，我坐在沙发上盯着电视，不时地叹气。
And strangely, Owen responded. He observed my weirdness for a while and then left. Then he came back and looked at me again and said one word-- "Mom"-- but in such a nice way that I smiled and said, Owen. And that was it. And then we sat there for a while, silently. I was surprised by how completely comfortable it felt. And then, finally, wordlessly, he got up and took his laundry upstairs.
奇怪的是，欧文做出了回应。他观察了我的怪异行为一会儿，然后离开了。然后他回来又看了我一眼，说了一个词——“妈”——但语气非常友好，以至于我笑了，说，“欧文”。就是那样。然后我们就坐在那里一会儿，沉默着。我惊讶于那感觉是多么完全的自在。然后，最后，他一言不发地站起来，把他的脏衣服拿到楼上去了。
Miriam Toews, she's a writer in Toronto. Her son, Owen, is now a grown man and Miriam tells us is long past his taciturn days. Her latest book is called A Truce That is Not Peace.
米里亚姆·托维斯，她是多伦多的作家。她的儿子欧文现在已经是一个成年人了，米里亚姆告诉我们他早就过了沉默寡言的阶段。她最新的书叫《一场并非和平的休战》。
Our program was produced today by Alex Blumberg and me with Wendy Dorr, Jonathan Goldstein, and Starlee Kine. Julie Snyder was our senior producer for this episode. Help on today's rerun from Molly Marcello, Stowe Nelson and Ruby Schwartz and Matt Tierney. Also, thanks to Dr. Martin Miner.
我们今天的节目由亚历克斯·布勒伯格和我制作，温迪·多尔、乔纳森·戈德斯坦和斯塔莉·凯恩参与。朱莉·斯奈德是我们这集的资深制片人。今天的重播得到了莫莉·马塞洛、斯托·尼尔森、鲁比·施瓦茨和马特·蒂尔尼的帮助。还要感谢马丁·迈纳医生。
This is our last week with Molly Marcello, who is our production fellow here at the show. She has been wonderful to work with. We all wish you the best.
这是我们和制作研究员莫莉·马塞洛在一起的最后一周。和她一起工作非常美妙。我们都祝你一切顺利。
Special thanks today to El Jefe, to Buzzy Goldstein, to Robert Howell, to Jim Nelson and GQ, Daniel Foster and Sarah Vowell. Alex Blumberg, who produced this week's show and did two of the stories in it-- these days, he is out of the radio game. He's running a building electrification and decarbonization platform called Daisy Chain Energy. If you reach out to him through his website, he'll tell you all about it.
今天特别感谢 El Jefe、巴兹·戈德斯坦、罗伯特·豪威尔、吉姆·尼尔森和《GQ》、丹尼尔·福斯特和萨拉·沃威尔。亚历克斯·布勒伯格，他制作了本周的节目并贡献了其中的两个故事——如今，他已经退出了电台行业。他正在经营一个名为 Daisy Chain Energy 的建筑电气化和脱碳平台。如果你通过他的网站联系他，他会告诉你一切。
Thanks, also, today to This American Life partners Michael Seaton, Cynthia Hill and Connie St. Clair. If you are somebody who enjoys our show-- and here you are listening all the way through the credits, so maybe that does describe you-- I invite you to please consider subscribing as a life partner. It helps us keep the show going.
今天还要感谢《美国生活》的合作伙伴迈克尔·西顿、辛西娅·希尔和康妮·圣克莱尔。如果你是一个喜欢我们节目的人——你一直听到这里，听完了演职员表，所以也许这确实在描述你——我邀请你考虑注册成为生活合作伙伴。这有助于我们让节目继续下去。
And as thanks, we've made dozens of bonus episodes. I've just been trying out doing a weekly newsletter, where basically I just talk about movies and books that I'm liking and recommend them to you. To join, go to thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners. The link is also in the show notes.
作为感谢，我们制作了几十期奖励集。我刚开始尝试做一份每周时事通讯，基本上我只是谈论我喜欢的电影和书籍并推荐给你。要加入，请访问 thisamericanlife.org/lifepartners。链接也在节目备注里。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who owns a very, very, very big radio. This is what he says about it.
《美国生活》由公共电台交流组织 PRX 传送到公共广播电台。像往常一样感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生，他拥有一台非常、非常、非常大的收音机。他是这么说的。
This big, shuddering, warm inanimate object would just drive me crazy. It was very, very erotic to me.
这个巨大的、颤抖的、温暖的、无生命的物体就会让我疯狂。它对我来说非常、非常色情。
I'm Ira Glass-- back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯——下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。